Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we're not going to have the usual visual
fireworks that we had with most topics in
computer graphics, but I really hope you'll
still find this episode enjoyable and stimulating.
This episode is also going to be a bit heavy
on what optimization is and we'll talk a little
bit at the end about the intuition of the
paper itself.
We are going to talk about mathematical optimization.
This term is not to be confused with the word
"optimization" that we use in our everyday
lives for, for instance, improving the efficiency
of a computer code or a workflow.
This kind of optimization means finding one,
hopefully optimal solution from a set of possible
candidate solutions.
An optimization problem is given the following
way: one, there is a set of variables we can
play with, and two, there is an objective
function that we wish to minimize or maximize.
Well, this probably sounds great for mathematicians,
but for everyone else, maybe this is a bit
confusing.
Let's build a better understanding of this
concept through an example!
For instance, let's imagine that we have to
cook a meal for our friends from a given set
of ingredients.
The question is, how much salt, vegetables
and meat goes into the pan.
These are our variables that we can play with,
and the goal is to choose the optimal amount
of these ingredients to maximize the tastiness
of the meal.
Tastiness will be our objective function,
and for a moment, we shall pretend that tastiness
is an objective measure of a meal.
This was just one toy example, but the list
of applications is endless.
In fact, optimization is so incredibly ubiquitous,
there is hardly any field of science where
some form of it is not used to solve difficult
problems.
For instance, if we have the plan of a bridge,
we can ask it to tell us the minimal amount
of building materials we need to build it
in a way that it remains stable.
We can also optimize the layout of the bridge
itself to make sure the inner tension and
compression forces line up well.
A big part of deep learning is actually also
an optimization problem.
There are a given set of neurons, and the
variables are when they should be activated,
and we're fiddling with these variables to
minimize the output error, which can be, for
instance, our accuracy in guessing whether
a picture depicts a muffin or a chihuahua.
The question for almost any problem is usually
not whether it can be formulated as an optimization
problem, but whether it is worth it.
And by worth it I mean the question whether
we can solve it quickly and reliably.
An optimizer is a technique that is able to
solve these optimization problems and offer
us a hopefully satisfactory solution to them.
There are many algorithms that excel at solving
problems of different complexities, but what
ties them together is that they are usually
handcrafted techniques written by really smart mathematicians.
Gradient descent is one of the simplest optimization
algorithms where we change each of the variables
around a bit, and as a result, see if the
objective function changes favorably.
After finding a direction that leads to the
most favorable changes, we shall continue
our journey in that direction.
What does this mean in practice?
Intuitively, in our cooking example, after
making several meals, we would ask our guests
about the tastiness of these meals.
From their responses, we would recognize that
adding a bit more salt led to very favorable
results, and since these people are notorious
meat eaters, decreasing the amount of vegetables
and increasing the meat content also led to
favorable reviews.
And we, of course, on the back of this newfound
knowledge, will cook more with these variable
changes in pursuit of the best possible meal
in the history of mankind.
This is something that is reasonably close
to what gradient descent is in mathematics.
A slightly more sophisticated version of gradient
descent is also a very popular way of training
neural networks.
If you have any questions regarding the gradient
part, we had an extended Two Minute Papers
episode on what gradients are and how to use
them to build an awesome algorithm for light
transport.
It is available, where?
Well, of course, in the video description
box, Károly, why are you even asking.
So what about the paper part?
This incredible new work of Google DeepMind
shows that an optimization algorithm itself
can emerge as a result of learning.
An algorithm itself is not considered the
same one thing as deciding what an image depicts
or how we should grade a student essay, it
is an algorithm, a sequence of steps we have
to take.
If we're talking about outputting sequences,
we'll definitely need to use a recurrent neural
network for that.
Their proposed learning algorithm can create
new optimization techniques that outperform
previously existing methods not everywhere,
but on a set of specialized problems.
I hope you've enjoyed the journey, we'll talk
quite a bit about optimization in the future,
you'll love it.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!